you
when gun violence erupts in America the
local mayor is often the first to try to
comfort families and heal the community
there have been more than 35,000
incidents of gun violence so far this
year blamed for more than 92 hundred
deaths 261 of those are considered mass
shootings Adriana Diaz before mayor's
one of whom had to respond to a massacre
less than two weeks ago they're part of
a growing bipartisan chorus of local
politicians pushing Congress to take
action on guns Adriana what are they
asking for well the mayor's want the
Senate to vote on bipartisan universal
background check bills that the House
already passed
mayor nan Whaley of Dayton Bobby Dyer of
Virginia Beach and Christine hunt offski
of parkland have all had to help their
cities heal after mass shootings we also
spoke with Washington DC Mayor Muriel
Bowser about daily urban gun violence
they all say it's time for action
mayor Whaley how is your community doing
we're in the process of grieving and so
people are in different places right now
I've been really amazed by just the
togetherness of the community and how
cohesive it's been and I think you know
there's still some shock out there mayor
Hentoff scoffs are you nodding your head
yeah yeah the first week shock is
probably the best way to describe it
when a mass shooting happens and it
happens in a place it's quote/unquote
not supposed to happen you lose trust in
everything you have called this now a
fraternity what does that mean it means
it's a fraternity no one ever wanted to
join there was no playbook there's
nothing that prepares a mayor for this
type of incident have mayor's reached
out to give you their best processes
yeah I mean I think so it's hundreds of
mayors and that's been like very
touching one of those hundreds was
Washington DC Mayor Muriel Bowser who
met with Mayor Whaley before our panel
discussion when you reached out to Mayor
Whaley what did you say I just shot her
a message that we loved her with her and
I know how resilient the people of
Dayton are but I also know that they
want to see
Bowser Whaley honkofsky and Dyer have
all signed a letter to Senate leaders
Mitch McConnell and Charles Schumer
demanding that the Senate approved to
universal background check bills that
the House passed in February mayor's
quickly move around the issue of gun
control because it affects our
communities so directly you saw this
past week 254 mayor's sign a letter to
say like hey sent it get to work and
pass background checks in all three of
your cases
shooters pass background checks so why
do you see that as the answer universal
background checks tied to risk
protection orders together can make a
difference I'm hopeful that we're
starting to see this movement happen now
you see that as a first step I guess
this could just start with that one
conversation with you know the
background checks where they might be
able to find consensus but then once you
start the dialogue then you can go into
the heavier things do you want to see an
assault weapons ban right now with the
partisanship going on I think we have to
establish the base first before we have
that given before the conversation let's
start with the background checks but
eventually I do think you know the way
to get rid of these shootings is to get
rid of the salt weapons and I just I
don't understand why anybody would need
the kind of gun that was on the oregon
district saturday night that killed nine
people in 32 seconds people make the
argument that even if you had no guts in
this country you still will have
incidents where there are mass
casualties which we have seen in this
case yes we have but you won't see 250 I
mean I think that's that's the point the
guns are just so easy to get a hold of
you're a Republican mayor you had this
incident happen in your community
did you change your views on and I am
more acutely aware I honestly think
right now the pro-gun people had some
good points and bad points and you know
the same is true for the opposition what
would you say to Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell you are a member of his
party you have been there you have seen
this up close what would you say to him
to bring about the policy changes you
want to see listen and learn from other
people take the opportunity to figure
out you know there may be
better ways to do anything can I just
say to this whole dichotomy of it's a
partisan issue it's only a partisan
issue in Washington DC
94% of Americans say universal
background checks it's not partisan in
the streets of Dayton and the streets of
Virginia Beach or the on the streets of
parkland what mayor Whaley said is spot
on in the business world you don't see a
problem and you have two people in the
company who say well I think this is the
answer and the other person calls them
then names and says no I think this is
the answer and then they both just go
away and don't do anything that is not
leadership that is not representation
and I think that is what you hear often
that the American people are just sick
of it's an issue the mayor say affect
all their cities whether they experience
mass shootings or urban gun violence
they're all connected to the prevalence
of guns and guns unchecked in our nation
we need to keep paying guns out of the
hands of people who have proven that
they're going to do damage with those
guns do you think this is the moment I
just pray it is Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell said recently he will
consider measures to reduce gun violence
when the Senate returns in September he
says he's open to stricter background
checks that was one of the things I
remember mayor Whaley last week after
after the the Dayton in El Paso
shootings when when she said all these
mayor's had called her that's when it
really struck me that you know point she
made yes said she said this is only a
partisan issue in Washington and it is a
fraternity no one wants to join but it's
so big now they're talking mostly about
background checks but we heard Bobby
dire they're mentioned the assault
weapons ban on our air we've been doing
reporting that that has facts on the
ground that led to the band in 94 and
that's not only mass shootings but we've
seen criminals using high-powered
weapons against police those in
California and then jury cos reporting
out of Philadelphia that's the context
here and I think they all say we got to
start somewhere
I mean we're all feeling so desperate
about this situation that's where they
all agree they represent different
parties but they agree on that first
step yeah Adriana thank you very much
powerful interviews